I have a few fun questions before we get
into what I call the real questions if
you could guessed right / Direct TV show
that's on right now what would you do
besides to the office don't mention the
IRS yeah I mean veep is off I thought
veep was perfect I would do veep I love
better things those would be mine I
really like love bluebloods I really
like um Tim Robinsons show usually not
hilarious that's fine we can move on I
got a plenty of questions okay what
movie what movie have you seen the most
Groundhog Day maybe European vacation
that is not the answer I was expecting
but I could totally understand that
yeah there's nothing wrong with that
movie it's great yeah actually watch
Groundhog Day every day that's how I'd
become a better person and okay except
that uh what TV show have you watched
all the way through more than once the
series oh yeah British office Breaking
Bad Sopranos or a nose oh so those like
a list some people are you know like a
tease the classic favorite ride at
Disneyland
okay sorry everyone at Collider no no
it's fine I I don't personally have a
favorite ride but there's a lot of
people that are very variable talking
about going there recently but I have
not so I you I'll follow up on this at
all say no more texture is there
anything that you guys collect they were
willing to talk about on camera
fungus I collect Hekla I collect nothing
okay trying to recollect anything that
is click , he said click on books I did
it was a big company let's cool um my
last quote unquote fun question uh was
your first movie or TV show crush civil
Shephard on moonlighting ok um I think
her name is Erin something from buck rod
I someone brought this up yesterday
Wilma Wilma darling
I think there's were a character name we
literally talked about this yesterday
Wow oh so I was transfixed I didn't know
the name would look like that yeah I I
completely agree with you it was when I
learned for myself that I had that I did
like women Yeah right yeah yeah that's
it Wilma
Buck Rogers yeah um so I've been asking
missable of everyone do you remember how
did you actually break into the industry
what was the thing that like obviously
you wanted to do what you're doing but
what was the thing that sort of got you
over that hurdle do you mean like even
just getting like the first job or you
mean a writing job first first way you
got a paid writing gig oh paid writing
gig
well I mean first paid writing I did was
I was a PA and a guy that I worked with
was producing a short film and he sent
me the script and said I'll pay you to
rewrite it and I think I made $100 I
rewrote the script that then the you
know like went to some festivals and
then I I got it I got I co-wrote a
script I was a writer's assistant on
this HBO show mind of the married man a
million years ago and I co-wrote what
ended up being the series finale uh and
that was my first ever that was my first
paper writing game so you went right for
the series finale yeah well yeah I was
like if I'm gonna do this then I'm gonna
shut this thing down right we're gonna
close this thing out art okay first
thing I got paid to write jokes for
stand-ups I would write jokes
dollars it wasn't enough to pay the rent
sure what about like a TV or movie we
wanna girl I mean we sold the pilot to
Fox yeah what was that 2004 yeah so the
pilot to Fox that we wrote that was
loosely based on us except we changed
writers to be magicians and then from
that script we got hired on the office
okay um that's pretty crazy yeah yeah
both both of the way that you guys got
in I hear such fascinating stories from
people yeah I'm sure
yeah it's um took us five yeah I mean we
were overnight we were assistants he was
a nanny you know five years into living
in LA that we have super job do you guys
have I've shown a lot of writers and
they have a lot of unproduced scripts do
you have a desk filled of unproduced
scripts or not really everything we ever
write is God knows I would say desk most
yeah definitely several W yeah there's
definitely scripts there's also there's
probably a stack of scripts and then a
gigantic stack of ideas
yeah goddamn what baked ideas what is
three different versions of ghostbusters
3 and better just sitting there I wasn't
gonna yeah I was gonna keep I was gonna
say what's the one script you have that
if you could get the green light on it
you would want to make it tomorrow
that's unproduced I mean I do think some
of the Ghostbuster scripts you wrote
were pretty strong it would be very
difficult with Harold having passed and
that sort of thing sure I think what
else we like best man jury duty we wrote
a script about TV script about jury duty
that we really liked
probably more TV stuff than yeah jumping
into I get to talk to you guys today so
what was the I guess talk a little bit
what the genesis of the project was it
like the first meeting with the studio
the first thing to get it off the ground
you know well you know we rewrote the
script first just wrote it on spec
because the bees are just
something we wanted to direct it so we
knew if we had a script we had we could
control the control yeah so we didn't
really you know we linked up with a
company that doesn't exist anymore
called good universe and which had done
blockers with point grave just seven
heavens company so we kind of got those
two entities together and then with two
went around and got some offers but they
had all the good universe and everyone
had red and stuff that haven't read the
script before before there's no pitching
it was basically we wrote the script
people said we want to do it and then
when we took into the studio's we kind
of talked about the feel of it the look
of it and all that sure so you you go
out with that the script people say yes
you somehow get the money to make this
thing yeah how much changes from that
day that your first you know from the
script you went out with to what people
are seeing on screen I mean everything
involves so you're always you know kind
of shaping it and and you know you have
to lose some things for financial
reasons and then an actor comes on you
may be shaped a little bit more towards
them the dynamics between the between
the three kids were so important so I
think as we started saying okay this
isn't something theoretical it's on a
page we now have Keith Williams Akito
Williams is very specific in a way
that's different from the character that
we wrote so now let's start writing
towards him or Brady is doing this thing
really well so you start really shaping
them and I think we kind of I think we
you know we kind of developed their arcs
more as we started getting into it and
feeling like what are we kind of driving
towards at the end of the movie yeah so
it's just you know the script the script
keep keeps evolving and then you shoot
and as you're shooting you discover
certain things and you want to protect
yourself in editing for something else
and then you get into editing and you
realize that thing that you thought was
so important doesn't matter and that
other thing really matters and so you're
trying to pull that up so just there's
all different times in the process where
you you're constantly discovering new
things completely what was I would
imagine you have three very you'll be
three young kids as the leads so what do
you get to film what eight hours a day
or is it it was nine right so that is it
changes the dynamic of filmmaking
completely yeah when you're through
leads our can only work so many hours
yeah we had to throw it a lot of our
ideas servers what we want to do with
the you know camera with the camera so
we just have to make sure we got at once
as scripted it was it was tough it was
definitely need to be really efficient
we talked to a lot to our DP about how
can we kind of cover the scene
effectively but also make sure that we
have a lot of covered yeah yeah but you
know I mean the good news is there all
of them have perfect complexions and so
there's not a lot of lighting and kind
of having to shoot around them in any
way and their hair you know if you like
some things that you sometimes have to
do with actors and actresses you don't
have to do with 12 year old 12 year olds
so the lighting would be a little bit
more minimal and we kind of we're a
little bit more down and dirty I think
then yeah so was there any take that you
you had five takes on anything or was it
because it seems to me like you need to
make your days yeah you're you can't go
over I mean there's there are welfare
workers on set they won't let you go one
minute over and you can't not make your
day because if you don't like we're only
in this hotel room today so it's not
like tomorrow we're in at the playground
and so if you're not you don't finish
what's here then you have to just leave
that's it like you have to make the
scene from what you have turn you have
to have it so was there any day that
went over five takes or ten takes
definitely not 10 we would also play
around like you know we would if we got
a line the way we wanted it we would try
a new line so that we would have options
at editing sure so what what was the
hardest sequence then to put together
with the restrictions that you were
dealt with you know it's funny and the
first day we kids riding their bikes and
talking and realize like that's gonna be
difficult for them to ride their bikes
and talk at the same time and then go
back to the you know the first area and
it was just like it was a mess so we had
to you know change things around and
maybe less bike riding and worse than
sitting on the straddling the bikes of
talking them things you don't think
about when you're right cuz we were we
were concerned as we started rewriting
the script that oh we're losing too much
bike riding we need bike riding that was
kind of one of the iconic feelings of
the movie and then after the first day
were like no more bike riding we need to
stop bike riding like we need to get
them walking yeah yeah I would have
never thought about that
it's so true I one of the things I
really liked and I'm gonna run this
after release is the ending of the movie
it shows their growth there's a great
line in the car about you know where the
girls are telling them about I miss
gonna misquote this thing but you know
who you're with as a kid is because of
you know your parents and where you live
and it's like this you know it's cool
this cool moment at the party where
they're all realizing what's going on so
talk a little bit about the ending and
where you wanted to go and was it always
that place the emotional core of the
movie was there was only one way you
could so we knew who it was gonna go
there and we spent a lot of time
thinking about it talking about it and
hopefully people will feel something
when they when they watch that oh no I
definitely you know I felt there was a
an honest conclusion to was it ever
something else or was it always this we
were always going for that feeling we
played around with there are lots of
different versions of it like that one
point they're erasing back to get back
they had big recital that night so
they're racing back for the recital and
then the kissing party kind of took over
that idea and we really wanted that you
know the kind of the iconic first and
then the recital was something that kind
of comes after that you know so we we
ended up keeping that but like all the
boys were in the recital and so as we
started kind of separating them out to
say max is into kissing and he's into
this and you know what are their
problems and what are their concerns
that kind of informed how the how the
ending sure what was it like
because obviously you met with other you
must have met with a lot of kids for the
roles yeah so what was it like trying to
figure out the three leads in terms of
the chemistry and I mean how long was
that process nine months it's like we
birthed yeah yeah right so talk a little
bit about was Jacob always in it yeah so
he was the linchpin yeah and then what
was it like how many times like for
example was it tons of kids that he was
chemistry reading with or was it he
lives in Vancouver he came down to LA
once or twice but we were kind of going
through trying to find I mean we were we
were in casting or watching tapes for
forever I mean we saw I learned as I'm
watching TV now I'm like oh yeah I
remember that kid I remember her yeah I
mean we saw everyone there's no there's
no good actor that yeah that we don't
that we don't know at this point and
you're just friend you're trying to find
that chemistry and you know you also
something you know to me it's like I
always have kind of like I have an idea
of how the line should be delivered in
my head and you know 100 kids can come
through and it won't sound like that
you're like [ __ ] maybe I'm wrong and
then all of a sudden Brandi noon walks
into the room and just kind of just
gives it exactly where that you wanted
it and and then even more and you're
like oh I'm amazing or Keith comes in
and I've never I've never heard someone
kind of been tone like that or pause at
that moment and all of a sudden you're
like oh this kid needs to be in the
movie
I heard that there was a scene with
Keith I think in the playground yelling
at Molly yeah or something like a 20
minute improv that was cut or am I wrong
about this I think that's what she told
me
playground or no he's in the parking
garage maybe it's a park now yeah right
so it sounds to me like all the kids you
put in the movie could like think on
their feet yeah I mean look they they're
really funny and they were just do
surprising things and they're not you
know they're not Steve Carell or Will
Ferrell or Melissa McCarthy sure and
they will get there at some point I
believe but yeah they they're doing
things that those people won't do
because they they have no background in
it so you're constantly surprised I mean
there are things that the character that
the actor said as themselves that we put
in the movie oh god um my last thing for
you what was it like filming the kissing
scene with Jacob because I asked him
what seeing terrified him and he's like
the kissing scene yeah by a mile
yeah you know what I mean so what is it
like filming that with kids who clearly
have no experience and are scared out of
their minds there's no joking around we
took all the kids in the circle about
what we were doing and he was yeah he
was definitely nervous and
you know there was a second kissing
scene of the movie for him first and
then the first casinos with the doll
sure hen then with the actual like human
beings we ease his way towards humans
right yeah there's so many things in
this movie that those kids are gonna
watch as adults and it'd just be don't
validate what they were doing yeah it's
great I listened I had a blast watching
this thing and I wish you guys nothing
but the best let me hit